okay we have a very exciting session
coming up about individual fairness
first college given by Professor Tim
Roth the University of Pennsylvania this
is going to talk about some exciting
work with some amazing colleagues
Thank You Steven yeah so this is with
joint work with with a bunch of students
former students and now grand students
so that's with my colleague Michael
Kern's our current PhD students Chris
who's right there SEF Steven who was our
former student who's now at Minnesota
and Steven student Logan so okay we're
all here at a fairness workshops I don't
need any motivation but you've all seen
these headlines there's lots of
justifiable concern that as we deploy
machine learning algorithms in
consequential domains that they are
exacerbating or perpetuating you know
unfairness whatever that means
okay so it's easy to worry about this
stuff but definitions are tricky right
so what does it mean that that something
is unfair and
but large you know when you when you
look at the academic literature on this
I would say there's sort of two major
families of definitions okay and I'm
gonna follow up a little bit on Sherrod
and others yesterday too first sort of
beat up on what I'm gonna call the the
sort of family of statistical fairness
measures and then and then talk about
but but first let's maybe like walk
through how you might like why you might
like statistical fairness measures right
let's let's try to go through maybe like
an exercise maybe on a lending setting
asking ourselves how we might like like
what we might mean when we when we say
that a classifier was unfair and one way
you might try to ask that question is by
starting off and asking the question who
was harmed okay like who was harmed by
the mistakes made by the algorithm the
decisions of the algorithm and one
possible answer you might come up with
is that you know the people that we feel
were harmed were somehow the qualified
applicants who were mistakenly rejected
and if that's the answer you come up
with then you might reasonably arrive at
sort of this idea that maybe the false
negative rate is something we should be
interested in when we think about
fairness because if the people who were
harmed were the qualified applicants who
were mistakenly rejected then the false
negative rate seems to be the rate at
which harm is done
yes that's right
and this is not going to be the thing
that I talk about in this talk but yes
so there are yes I'm not like proposing
that's what we do
but like this is sort of a popular
definition in the literature that maybe
we should try to equalize false negative
rates across groups and this is sort of
just one of maybe all family of
statistical fairness measures if you
want to come up with your own
statistical fairness measure here's the
exercise you can go through you can
partition the world into groups often
according to some protected attribute to
maybe race or gender you can pick your
favorite statistic of the classifier it
could be false positive rate or false
negative rate or positive predictive
value or just draw a classification
right there's a lot of these and you can
ask that the statistic should be
approximately equalized across groups so
I would say like you know by volume at
least this family of fairness
definitions is like by far the most
popular in the academic literature if
you just look at like the number of
papers written about okay but there's
sort of a number of reasons not to like
definitions like this sort of dating
back to the catalog of evils from the
door cat all fairness through awareness
paper and let me just sort of give a
like a cartoon example of one of them
okay so you know suppose let's think
again maybe about like false negative
rates then and in a lending application
and we've got two attributes that two
protected attributes that we care about
like race the blue and green and gender
male and female and we say we want the
false negative rates to be equalized
across these groups men and women and
green people and suppose actually that
the sort of labels that we're trying to
predict are totally uncorrelated with
either of these features okay so you
know there's a bunch of ways to make
classification decisions to equal as
false negative rates across these groups
here's
one of them probably not the one that
you wanted when you specified these
constraints I could give loans to people
exactly when they are blue men or green
women okay that does in fact equalize
false negative rates across race and
gender it's 50% and in each row it's 50%
in each column
but that's cold comfort if you're a
green man
it promises you nothing like green men
should have deterministically are denied
loans okay like right the problem is
like by sort of very explicitly right
these notions of statistical fairness
only offer guarantees about the average
behavior of a classifier over large
groups like that's how they're defined
there are constraints on averages over
large populations they're not
constraints on individuals and so like
if you think about the meaning of these
constraints like what a statistical
fairness constraint promises to you it
potentially promises you nothing right
like if you're in one of these two
quadrants like despite these fairness
constraints you are getting nothing
right right and more generally like you
know it you can interpret them as a
promise to you only if you sort of
subjectively believe that you are a
uniformly random member of one of these
protected groups so there are stronger
sort of notions of fairness individual
fairness again dating back to this
fairness through awareness paper that
offer constraints that actually bind on
individuals right pairs of individuals
rather than averages over groups that
sort of get around this problem okay and
this particular fairness constraint
tries to formalize the semantics that
similar individuals should be treated
similarly so like to find a little bit
more generally in that paper but but
sort of one instantiation of that is
that given some task specific similarity
metric D given some way of measuring how
similar pairs of people are for the task
at hand we should treat similar people
similarly which might mean for example
that for any pair of people the
difference in probability that they for
example are given alone should not
differ by more than their their distance
in the similarity metric so in
particular like if two people are
distance zero if they're like equally
qualified for the task at hand they
should get the loan say with exactly the
same probability okay so this is a nice
family of definitions because it binds
it right and it's an individual notion
of fairness because the constraint like
explicitly binds on particular
individuals as opposed to averages over
people like most of the problems that
arise catalog of evils for statistical
notions of fairness come from the fact
that these statistical constraints are
just constraints that our averages over
large populations so the like immediate
complication is that the metric here is
is like doing a lot of the work and and
where do we get this metric and trying
to answer this question has has been
sort of the focus of a lot of the work
subsequent to the original fairness
through awareness paper
okay so so I want to sort of think about
one way to sort of operationalize this
something that's not quite this but in
the spirit of this where we want to sort
of treat similar individuals similarly
okay so imagine that we impanel a group
of AI ethics experts okay so you know by
AI ethics experts I don't mean people
that deeply you know understand the
problem I don't mean people that have
opinions you agree with I just mean
people who have opinions people who you
know you can like ask questions like you
know do you think this pair of people
this pair of people should be treated
similarly or not and so like clearly
this is going to be a contentious
process like it's hard to find groups of
AI ethics experts that that people will
agree on but but I would sort of argue
that like no matter what your proposal
is to try to sort of implement some kind
of measure of fairness there's there's
no avoiding some step like this and that
different people mean different things
when they say you know and before doing
anything like a necessary first step is
to like figure out who you're going to
who you're gonna listen to okay so like
you know imagine that you know you get
to choose who these people are okay the
people whose opinions you must respect
okay so so what should we like expect
from this group of people so it seems
you know maybe too much to expect that
the experts could like write down a
fairness metric that they could sort of
express their their you know conception
of fairness as like a concisely defined
quantitative metric you know it's not
even clear we should expect that their
subjective judgments would even be like
implicitly consistent with any metric
maybe the problem is not just one of
Xpress tivity but that you know like
they're right they're sort of subjective
notions of fairness ours are somehow
like internally inconsistent like I
don't want to assume that there's any
like triangle inequality for example
here and you know if we have more than
one person on the panel it's sort of
certainly seems unlikely that the
experts would agree with one another in
every case like even if even if they
could like express their notion of
fairness in terms of some metric
probably they would have liked different
metrics still you know we can imagine
asking these people about about
particular case studies so you know for
two particular people and you can
imagine giving them sort of rich
information about them maybe more
information than the machine learning
algorithm has access to you know
whatever information you want that you
feel sort of correctly captures these
case studies you could ask them you know
should these two particular individuals
be treated similarly where we're being
treated similarly means something very
precise like should they for example be
given the same label or should the
probability that they're given a
positive label differ by more than you
know by like less than ten percent and
once you sort of you know even if you
don't assume anything about how the
people on this panel answer these
questions so you don't have to assume
consistency with a metric you don't have
to assume that they agree with one
another
there's nevertheless like already a
well-defined trade off to navigate okay
once we have a group of people who have
opinions it doesn't matter what their
opinions are
once we have a distribution over
individuals okay there's two things we
might care about there's the well the
classification error of the model we're
ultimately training and there's the
frequency with which the classifier
makes pairs of decisions that an expert
views as unfair right like once we have
a collection of people who who express
opinions and once we have a distribution
of our people in a classifier then there
is there's a well-defined rate over the
sort of draw of two new people from the
distribution that the classifier does
something that causes someone in this
panel of experts to complain okay and so
we can at least talk about this
trade-off how can we trade off the sort
of error rate of our classifier with the
sort of frequency with which it pisses
off someone on our AI ethics panel yeah
so for the for the purposes of this talk
just to make things simpler I'm going to
imagine that the panel is just one
person but more generally you could talk
about you know he had like a very large
panel the sort of expected number of
people on the panel who would complain
since they don't have it so in the paper
that sort of maybe the sort of more
relevant thing if it were a large panel
it would be the expected number of
people complaining but but here I'm
really gonna just talk about like one
person has a particular fire in mind
they're not supposed to but then they
could simply say that you know these
people were at zero and those people are
one and the difference in the they could
yeah yes so sort of the motivating that
the the thing driving a lot of this work
is the desire to like essentially make
no assumptions about how the panelists
are making their decisions so that is
certainly one thing they could do I had
thought that the panel
the panel had an image of distance but
so any given indecision doesn't
necessarily violate anything that's
right so I'm talking about pairs so this
is gonna be a frequency over drawers of
pairs of people once I have a pair of
people I have so it's like I think you
know this person I think that the
distance between these two people is a
half okay so I expect as any single time
where my higher right person gets the
Big E in the lower rank doesn't it's
fine any single time where the
higher-ranked doesn't and the lower does
it's also okay because you expect that
to happen some of the time you're
talking about the difference between
like the randomization and the
realization yeah so maybe for the
purposes of the talk let's let's think
about the experts directly having
opinions about and being able to observe
the probability is a positive
classification but but some of that like
like since we're talking about sort of
the expected number of times but the
analyst complained some of that sort of
will wash out even if they only like
complain about realizations
so let me talk of it let me talk about
sort of the pros and cons of two
different approaches to this one that
sort of it's not something we're trying
to do and sort of there's reasons you'd
want to do this there's reasons you'd
not want to do this and compare it to
what we're trying to do okay so sort of
one thing you might try to do is to sort
of decompose this process into like a
two-stage process okay so basically like
first try to learn like the metric or
the similarity function that the
individuals on your panel are sort of
implicitly making decisions respect to
so try to sort of learn the metric and
then once you have this this object this
sort of metric you've learned what you
hope sort of what captures you know the
intuitive judgments of the panel in the
sense that it will generalize
out-of-sample that it will sort of
capture their beliefs about pairs that
you haven't seen before you could try to
use this learn similarity function as a
constraint okay so that's not what we're
trying to do there are reasons to want
to do this no the first is that there's
a large literature you can draw on
people have studied metric learning and
there's sort of thoughtful recent work
by by Christina
there that you should read if you
haven't yes the sort of thinks about how
you would make queries for metric
learning to to human judges thinking
sort of carefully about what kinds of
questions are easier for human judges to
answer and the nice thing about this
approach is that if it works you
actually get the metric you have some
metric that you can try to interrogate
you can like ask questions about how
similar people are that you haven't seen
before and to the extent that the metric
you've learned generalizes out-of-sample
this may be lets you learn something
about the human conceptions of fairness
for the people on your panel
the cons are that if you want this
approach to work you have to make
assumptions about the form of the
judgments that the human experts are
making like in particular if this
approach is going to work it's got to be
that the human judges are making
decisions in a way that is consistent
with some with some decision rule that's
actually structurally simple right
that's because if you don't make that
assumption there's no way to generalize
out-of-sample there's no particular
reason if if they're not using a simple
decision rule that consistency with sort
of the judgments for people you've seen
will will say anything at all about
judgments you haven't seen a particular
like if you're gonna try to do this from
the features you have to assume that the
experts of judgment is a function only
of the features so that's not what we're
doing we're not attempting at all to
learn the metric we're not trying to
learn the encoding of the experts
similarity judgment okay instead we're
gonna try to directly learn a classifier
that doesn't violate the constraints of
the experts similarity judgment more
than some bounded amount we'll have some
parameters that sort of give us flak in
various ways and the main pro of this
approach is that to do this it turns out
you can solve this learning problem in a
generalizable way without making
essentially any assumptions at all about
the experts similarity judgments okay so
we don't have to assume that they're
from some sort of simple family okay and
from my perspective I mean like the nice
thing about of having fewer assumptions
is that it's less likely they're gonna
be violated especially when we're
talking about something sort of
ill-defined I think as you know like
people's subjective judgments that
there's not a lot of assumptions that I
sort of feel comfortable making here and
so so this is a nice thing that in this
approach it turns out you don't have to
make essentially any assumptions the con
of course is that you don't get the
metric like you don't get the metric as
an object to interrogate you just get
the classifier
okay so there's some related work sort
of sort of a few years ago we had a
paper where we tried to do something
similar in a slightly more difficult
learning setting and online learning
setting with adversarial arrivals
instead of a distributional setting but
and we sort of wanted to give like a
polynomial time algorithm but like the
the big problem with this work is we had
to make very strong assumptions about
the form of the human judgments namely
that they were consistent not just with
a metric but about with a metric of a
very simple form okay
Michael and O'Mara and guy also had a
paper where they sort of gave they also
don't have to make assumptions about the
form of of these sort of judgments and
they did it by giving a sort of group
fairness version of metric fairness
using the multi fairness technology that
you heard guy and and Michael talked
about yesterday so so essentially but
for a very rich collection of groups the
sort of average difference in
classification for a pair randomly
selected from that group should not
differ by more than the average distance
between people in that group guy and gal
thought about the question of
generalization for metric fairness so
sort of an orthogonal problem although
like related to like the generalization
guarantees I'm gonna talk about but but
sort of they're thinking of the metric
as given and they're worried just about
generalization and then again Christina
has this nice paper thinking about how
you should actually interrogate sort of
human beings right if you're metric
Oracle is like a human being for the
task of learning a metric
so let's sort of now write down a model
so we've got a set of one or more judges
okay but for this talk I want to just
think about it as one judge to save on
some notation okay and like a judge is
sort of the way we think about a judge
is sort of a like a simple object the
judges just parametrized by like an
arbitrary collection of pairs of
individuals that she thinks should be
treated similarly okay so for example if
you want to think about these as sort of
opinions just about binary outcomes
maybe there are pairs of individuals
that she thinks should always get the
same binary outcome or if you want to
think about probabilities maybe these
are sort of pairs of individuals that
she thinks should get positive
classification with probabilities that
differ by no more than 10% okay more
generally a lot of what I'm gonna say
will generalize to sort of or
quantitative judgments like maybe you
actually have an opinion about like how
differently it's okay to treat pairs of
people but for the talk and actually for
the paper I'm gonna think about limiting
this to binary judgments and we don't
necessarily and sort of the important
thing is this can be like an arbitrary
collection of pairs we're assuming no
structure on it so we can query the
judges about pairs right they tell us if
a particular pair should be treated
similarly or not and okay and and so now
let's think about sort of measures of
unfairness given some distribution of
our classifiers some randomized
classifier okay let's say that you know
let's suppose that the questions were
asking the judges are do you think that
this pair of individuals should be you'd
be given a positive label or it should
not be given a positive label with
probabilities that differ by more than
ten percent okay in that case think
about gamma here as being ten percent
so let's say that a game a violation for
a pair given a randomized classifier a
10% violation for a pair well if the
judge doesn't think that these people
should be treated similarly than the
violation is zero okay if the judge
thinks these people should be treated
similarly up to some slack of 10% and in
fact the probabilities of them getting a
positive label are within 10% the
violations also zero otherwise the
violation is the degree to which the
classifications are the difference in
classification probabilities exceeds 10%
these are randomized classifiers it's a
distribution of our classifiers and the
judges can only express the opinion that
two people should be treated similarly
not that they should be treated
dissimilar that's right
yeah I think some of what we say could
be generalized to them expressing an
opinion the people should be treated
just similarly but yes let's say that
the opinions are only that people should
be treated similarly not that they
should be treated distantly so in
particular like yeah like in fact just
for feasibility like the reason why the
optimization problem we're gonna write
down is always feasible is like the
assumption is if you treat everyone
identically then it's okay sort of the
gamma violation for a pair of people
what do you do with more than this is
for one judge would either
today today's talk is one dredge more
generally you'd look at sort of the at
more generally we'd look at the average
of this over the judges is a question
okay are the people being judged from
the training center from a separate set
yes so we're gonna talk about
generalization but we will ultimately
have some like training set which is the
only place from which we can get both
sort of judgments from the panel and
also you know like train our classifier
and we're gonna be interested in both
the accuracy and the fairness but I'm
gonna give you in a moment
out-of-sample okay this still sort of
implies that the metric is simple enough
so we're not gonna need to assume
anything about the metric which the cost
for that is that we won't be able to
like answer metric queries but but we're
gonna be able to guarantee that the
classifier still doesn't violate the
constraint so I'm gonna write down but
that is gonna be the main thing that we
the sort of benefit of this approach as
opposed to learning the metric is that
we need to assume almost nothing about
the form of the judgments so this is the
violation for a particular pair and like
in general our goal is going to be to
find some classifier that has low error
subjects subject to the constraint that
the gamma violate the expected gamma
violation over a randomly drawn pair
from this unknown distribution P should
be small less than ADA okay so we have
to sort of two approximation parameters
that we can play with there's gamma
which is sort of like this L infinity
constraint and there's ADA which is sort
of like this l1 constraint
in sample we can sort of we're gonna be
able to make both of these you know as
close to zero as you like out-of-sample
it turns out that the thing that you're
gonna have to relax a little bit is ADA
so that's sort of the problem and and
it's okay so we can write that down as
an empirical risk minimization problem
this is nothing other than sort of a
sort of optimization version of what you
saw on the last slide so what we'd like
to do is we would like to find a
distribution over classifiers in some
class H okay and we're also in this sort
of the version of this optimization
problem writing down there's another set
of variables which are sort of think of
them as slack variables okay we would
like to we would like to minimize error
error over learnt classifier subject to
the constraint that for every Cohen when
I'm writing down this optimization
problem just to make things simple like
imagine that I've queried the judges on
every pair of people in my training set
but in general you don't actually need
to do that you could query a small
random sample of pairs in the training
set okay but just so that I don't have
to write some notation relating to like
who I've sampled let's imagine that I've
queried the judges if I have a training
set of size n on all N squared pairs
okay so the constraints are the
following for every pair of people that
the judges think should be treated gamma
similarly I want that well they should
be treated gamma similarly the
probability that they are classified as
positive should differ by no more than
gamma if it does differ by more than
gamma it'll have to be captured in this
slack variable alpha right so this is
sort of the L infinity constraint this
is gonna fold into the L 1 constraint
and this constraint is just saying the
average value of these slack variables
should be among people that the judges
think should be treated similarly should
be small less than ADA
okay so so ADA and gamma
our constants these are sort of the
approximation parameters that you when
writing down this optimization problem
can decide you can't really know
anything about distances for people you
don't see then essentially just need to
assume the worst about everybody good
question we haven't thought about that
so carefully in the sense that we've run
some experiments that I'll show you at
the end and so you can sort of four
particular people's judgments on
particular datasets trace out what the
Pareto curves look like but this right
that's right so all of these things will
interact and I don't know how to say
anything clean one way or the other
about that but that's not to say that
something couldn't be said I just
yeah that seems that seems sensible so
certainly you know for some judgments
you know there's like nothing you can do
better than like a constant classifier
so this is like the optimization problem
something that's feasible let's just
give it a name there's these two
parameters call it gamma ADA
subjectively fair in sample and our goal
right that we have two goals one is sort
of the optimization problem we'd like to
solve the in-sample optimization problem
and then the other is that sure that
it's guarantees both in terms of
accuracy and fairness and generalize
out-of-sample Oh so let's think about
those in turn so and first like what
should we hope for so it's sort of too
much in the way I've set up the problem
to hope for like a polynomial time
algorithm because unconstrained learning
like it's minimizing error forgetting
these constraints that's already
computationally hard in the worst case
even for the very simplest of learning
problems it's just like learning linear
classifiers that's hard to approximate
already but like this is sort of the
canonical example of a domain where
worst-case hardness results have had the
least bite like these problems are all
like really hard in the worst case you
can't to even to any non-trivial factor
approximate to the accuracy of the best
linear classifier in the worst case and
yet like we have heuristics that solve
these problems very well all the time
right so for for for the proper you know
linear problems and for much harder
problems so we shouldn't we can't hope
for like a polynomial time algorithm
that's gonna solve the problem in the
way that I've set it up but what kind of
thing we can hope for is like an Oracle
efficient algorithm like some efficient
reduction to the unconstrained learning
problem so if you have some heuristic
that you believe solves unconstrained
learning problems
well then maybe what we can do is using
that heuristic solved
learning problem via a reduction to like
a small number of unconstrained by the
framework is sort of you know like open
to abuse because these are Oracle's that
solve NP hard problem so you could you
know like write down algorithms that use
gadget reductions and solve Traveling
Salesman problem with you know one
Oracle call but like you don't abuse the
methodology then it tends to produce
practical algorithms and if I have time
I'll show you a couple of experimental
results at the end
okay so you know the or the kind of
Oracle's we're going to assume that we
have our Oracle's that can solve
weighted classification problems so
given a data set it'll always just be
our training data set we're not going to
construct funny data sets with yeah
funny gadget reductions we're just going
to assume that we have algorithms that
can solve just the standard old
empirical risk minimization problem on
weightings of our original data set and
an Oracle efficient algorithm is just an
algorithm that is polynomial time
assuming it has access to an Oracle for
solving problems like this so brief
sketch of solving the computational
problem it uses like my favorite trick
think about it as a zero-sum game so
you've got some constrained optimization
problem but the Lagrangian duality you
can think of it as a unconstrained min
max problem okay like a game if you like
played between the learner the person
controlling the primal variables and the
dual player someone who's controlling
the dual variables okay so you just have
your original objective and remember we
have two kinds of constraints we have
these sort of constraints for every pair
of people so every pair of people in
your training set gets a dual variable
okay and we have this sort of
expectation constraint that gets its own
dual variable and this is now an
unconstrained min max problem then we're
going to compute an equilibrium of this
game a Nash equilibrium of this game in
particular the equilibrium for the
primal player is just the solution to
your original unconstrained optimization
problem by having the dual player play
an algorithm like multiplicative weights
or gradient descent to any algorithm
that has a no regret guarantee okay that
you can do efficiently in this case
because there's only a relatively small
number of dual variables okay so you can
efficiently run this algorithm and we're
gonna have the primal player play best
response meaning at each iteration for
every fixed value you know at each
iteration there will be some fixed
values for the dual player the thing
we'll need the primal player to do at
every iteration
just solve this minimization problem
over yeah he's gonna find a classifier
and some setting for the slack variables
and what you have to make sure you can
do is you can you're right the the dual
player is always like efficient the
thing you want to figure out how to do
is how to use your weighted
classification Oracle to implement the
best response step so I'm running short
on time so I won't like go through the
details but suffice it to say you can do
that like to solve the best response
problem you just have to do two things
one is solve a weighted classification
problem for with weights that are a
function of the dual variables and you
have to set each of the slack variables
but each of those is sort of just a an
independent you have to compute like
some inequality for each of the slack
variables and the upshot is you know
that there is in fact an Oracle
efficient algorithm that has run time
that's you know polynomial everything
you care about I'm just writing
polynomial here but but actually this is
just sort of like the convergence bound
of gradient descent so it's not a
terrible polynomial that has error that
is sort of equal to the objective that
we're trying to compete with and
satisfies subjective fairness that has
just a little bit more slack in this
like l1 constraint okay and the
algorithm kind of works so we're yeah so
actually you don't need all pairs you
need sort of it's enough to sort of
randomly sample something like like
vc-dimension many pairs so you don't
actually need like quadratically many
pairs it's more like linearly many pairs
oh let me just say a little bit about
generalization which is mostly standard
rated there's nothing complicated going
on here if I look at the empirical
fairness laws for like a particular
classifier right which is just like the
average over all of the pair's in my
dataset of this like gamma fairness
violation term this is you know like
it's like a 1 in n sensitive function
right because if I change one data point
I can change and terms here but but
there's like I'm dividing by N squared
so by like McDermott's inequality this
thing exhibits turn off like
concentration for any particular very
particular classifier it's extremely
unlikely that on two samples that we
have a very different like fairness loss
and so by sort of us like a standard
like to sample trick and Sowers lemma I
can get uniform convergence so for all
of the deterministic classifiers in my
class with a sort of sample complexity
that depends only on the VC dimension of
the class for this fairness loss the
only complication is that this is sort
of uniform convergence over just the
deterministic classifiers for error that
would be enough to get uniform
convergence over the randomized
classifiers as well here the fairness
loss is not a linear function in the
mixture weights if I have a randomized
classifier so it's not enough but it's
not too hard to get around that problem
you once you have uniform convergence
for the deterministic classifiers you
can take an epsilon net over the
distributions
the upshot is that you sort of get the
same statement but but now with
out-of-sample bounds so there's an
Oracle efficient algorithm it's got
sample complexity committee complexity
like the number of times you have to
like ask someone for a pair and running
time that's all polynomial and the
parameters you care about that finds a
distribution of our classifiers that
competes with optimal and is
subjectively fair with a little bit more
slack on this l1 constraint but now
out-of-sample okay and we didn't have to
assume any any structure on the judges
preference in what way is it off so this
is just like when I wrote down the like
empirical risk minimization problem this
is the error of the minimal error
classifier that satisfies Gama ada
subjective fairness on the distribution
just classification error so I don't
have too much time we ran some
experiments we use the compas data set
okay it's not enough to have a data set
in this setting we have to have like
human judges so we are human judges were
43 undergraduates from some major
American research university they had
taken a course on okay just taking a
course on algorithmic fairness these are
extremely preliminary so like there's
lots to complain about these experiments
the main takeaway it's just that you can
run the algorithm so yes so we're sort
of a the compass data set we showed each
edge 5050 randomly selected pairs right
data points from the compass data set we
showed them the features which are
things like gender age race and then
statistics about their criminal history
we didn't we consciously did not show
them the outcome because otherwise you'd
think they would just suggest that you
should classify people similarly if they
have the same outcome okay and then from
this data we like ran our algorithm
there's like a couple questions you
could ask maybe the first one is just
like does the algorithm
even work we have like a theorem that
says it works assuming that you have an
Oracle for unconstrained learning of
course we don't have an Oracle we just
have a heuristic something based on
linear regression okay but it seems that
the algorithm works so here's sort of a
simple convergence plot what you're
seeing is the iterates of the algorithm
as we run it on the x-axis is the error
of the classifier is that each iterate
on the y-axis is is gamma the sort of
maximum fairness of violation term here
we set like a de to be 0 and we set
gamma to be 30% and what you see is that
the thing seems to converge that is it
starts at the sort of unconstrained
error optimal thing and then it seems to
sort of come up exactly to this target
gamma parameter 30 or so it's the when
you went when someone is said to be yeah
what it's treated similarly mean their
classification probability should be
within 30 percent here ada is zero so it
just means for every pair you can draw a
Pareto curves for different
undergraduates they're different so
people don't have like a consistent
notion of fairness when you ask them
questions like this there's some other
stuff you can do we haven't done it yet
so if the student said that a should be
treated like B and B should be treated
like see what was the chance
yeah that's a great question and that's
one of the things we haven't done yet
but with better data that's definitely a
question you could ask so we have only
very preliminary the algorithm sort of
works you can run it but we don't know
we haven't done much to interrogate like
human notions of fairness although
that's something you could conceivably
do okay thank you the judges to define
similarity so I guess like you know
practically speaking isn't the same
issue absolutely so there's like
certainly all sorts of experimental
design questions that we haven't even
like attempted to think about yet that's
something we're interested in but we
haven't done yet
you just related this but I hope I
didn't miss anything it seems like the
solicitations especially in groups
possibly found acceptable
well the the people that we're listening
from are unaffected by the outcome so
there's not a natural notion of
incentive compatibility it's not clear
why you as like the undergraduate in
this class would have any like utility
for yes the the people who the outcomes
effects are different from the people
whose preferences were eliciting seems
like the judges do have preferences over
what what goes into practice maybe
through global preferences or caring
about some acetals event I'll take it
offline